we begin with more drama from Washington
and the swamp today after two days six
ballots uh Republican leader Kevin
McCarthy has not gotten to the magic
number of 218 to be Speaker of the House
20 Republicans continue to oppose
McCarthy including congresswoman Lauren
bobert she'll join us live in just a
moment now today bobert along with 19
others they voted for Congressman Byron
Donalds Donald's is a rising star for
sure within the GOP strong conservative
track record but radical Democrat Corey
Bush she just referred to him as a prop
and accused Byron Donalds of quote
upholding and perpetuating white
supremacy this is your Democratic
Socialist inclusive woke party now he
said his name being in the mix is not
progress it's pathetic now just imagine
living with that much hate and that much
vitriol Cory Bush must be a pretty
miserable human being or maybe she's
just jealous Democrats have never even
flirted with the idea of making her
speaker and guess what Corey Bush they
likely never will so so much for your
definition of progress but to his credit
Congressman Donalds is attempting to
bring down the temperature on Capitol
Hill with this important reminder we are
on day two of the speaker battle not day
200. Donald is Right despite all the
squawking from the Democrats their
friends in the media mob this is not a
crisis yet it's not should Republicans
have worked all this out in private long
before yesterday yeah absolutely and
behind the scenes I can tell you I spoke
to many of them and I urged many of them
to work it out they apparently did not
listen to my advice now is it the
disaster the media mob and Democrats
want not yet by a long shot there's
nothing wrong about taking a few days to
decide who will fill a very important
and Powerful position in the House of
Representatives and there's one other
take here unlike Democrats members of
the Republican Party they're not sheep
who are you know will do what they are
told but still an overwhelming majority
of Republicans over 200 to 20 prefer
McCarthy for obvious reasons he already
laid out his commitments to America
that's the America first mega agenda he
vowed to stop Biden's Reckless agenda he
also detailed all the investigations and
the oversight that would take place
under his watch and you may remember
McCarthy also agreed to what is called a
motion to vacate the speakership all
that would need of five Republican votes
and that would be a serious insurance
policy in the event that Kevin McCarthy
didn't live up to his promises that was
a huge ask and a huge give but the bar
keeps changing now tonight I don't have
a crystal ball I can't tell you how long
this will take I can't predict what will
happen like many of you watching I just
want them to get working I want
oversight of the Biden Administration I
want his family's business dealings
investigated I want the FBI and the doj
probe for bias and abuse of power I want
our border secure I want our economy to
recover I want to return to energy
Independence and Republicans if they're
ever going to take back power and turn
this great country around they will need
to Rally around real issues that matter
to millions of Americans out there Coast
to Coast what I can tell you tonight is
this that the one thing that House
Republicans seem to all agree on is that
agenda hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else